Katrina: 够用吗
Katrina: Will it be enough?
Jake:那就买几个杯子
Jake: Then let's buy a few cups.
Katrina: 好的收到
Katrina: Okay, got it.
Katrina: 他不给用
Katrina: He won't let us use...
Katrina: 一次性杯子
Katrina: Disposable cups.
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: You get it?
Katrina: 好买呃
Katrina: Fine, buy it... uh.
Jack: 严格follow Essex review的要求
Jack: Strictly follow Essex review requirements.
Katrina: 那个杯子在这
Katrina: That cup is here.
Katrina: 好像咱有几个
Katrina: Looks like we have a few.
Katrina: 差不多要有20个人
Katrina: Almost 20 people.
Shure: 就Isaac绑架
Shure: Just like Isaac kidnapping...
Katrina: 杯子杯子
Katrina: Cups, cups.
Shure: 这就是视视觉错觉是吧
Shure: This is an optical illusion, right?
Shure: 别没等那到那就碎了
Shure: Don't let it break before we get there.
Shure: 这玩意放底下真的安全吗
Shure: Is it really safe to put this thing underneath?
Katrina: 不知道哇
Katrina: I don't know, wow.
Shure: 我感觉他绝对等不到我们结账就得碎
Shure: I feel like it will definitely break before we finish paying.
Katrina: 买什么汁
Katrina: What juice should we buy?
Katrina: 橙汁啊有桃汁了
Katrina: Orange juice, right? We already have peach juice.
Katrina: 太好了养乐多
Katrina: Great, Yakult.
Katrina: 上养乐多
Katrina: Let's get Yakult.
Katrina: 应该没事吧
Katrina: It should be fine, right?
Katrina: 他拿的是什么味
Katrina: What flavor did he get?
Katrina: 西柚汁
Katrina: Grapefruit juice.
Katrina: 再来一瓶西柚吧
Katrina: Let's get another bottle of grapefruit.
Katrina: 酒要买一瓶
Katrina: We need to buy a bottle of alcohol.
Katrina: 龙舌兰还要买旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Tequila, and we also need to buy Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 全是饮料这
Katrina: It's all drinks here.
Katrina: 两天感觉就是摄入的有点那个
Katrina: Feels like we've been consuming a bit too much in two days.
Katrina: 得糖尿病
Katrina: Gonna get diabetes.
Katrina: 对我也好像一天到晚没喝过矿泉水
Katrina: Yeah, I feel like I haven't drunk any mineral water all day.
Katrina: 你下午没睡觉吗
Katrina: You didn't take a nap this afternoon?
Katrina: 啊你一直在配环境
Katrina: Ah, you've been setting up the environment?
Katrina: 看看这个
Katrina: Look at this.
Katrina: 帮我抬一下
Katrina: Help me lift it.
Katrina: 拿拿过去
Katrina: Take it over there.
Shure: 不是你们会扒吗
Shure: Don't you guys know how to peel it?
Katrina: 不会买现成的呗
Katrina: No, just buy the ready-made ones.
Shure: 这是三室的
Shure: This is a three-room one.
Shure: 这个啊四个应该是
Shure: This one should be four.
Choiszt: 你要买一个熟一点
Choiszt: You should buy a riper one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Katrina: 什么叫三室
Katrina: What do you mean by three-room?
Shure: 就是三个瓣和四个瓣
Shure: It means three sections or four sections.
Shure: 就是拆开之后
Shure: When you open it up,
Shure: 你大概看他那个轮廓能看出来
Shure: you can roughly see the outline.
Katrina: 你咋
Katrina: How do you
Katrina: 这能从外面看出来
Katrina: Can you tell from the outside?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Nicous: 新加坡榴莲不应该很便宜
Nicous: Shouldn't durians in Singapore be very cheap?
Jake:就这些东西
Jake: These things,
Jake:我觉得随便买到这我觉得不划算
Jake: I feel like buying them here is not worth it.
Katrina: 感觉是
Katrina: Feels like it is.
Shure: 我们上次是不是还买山
Shure: Did we buy mangosteen last time?
Shure: 竹来着
Shure: The mangosteen?
Katrina: 对还没吃完在一楼
Katrina: Yeah, we haven't finished it, it's on the first floor.
Shure: 我想吃我一直惦记这块
Shure: I want to eat it, I've been thinking about it.
Shure: 我山竹惦记好久啊
Shure: I've been craving mangosteen for so long.
Katrina: 山竹啥味啊
Katrina: What does mangosteen taste like?
Katrina: 甜味哈哈
Katrina: It's sweet, haha.
Shure: 你知道这
Shure: You know this...
Shure: 这其实是东北特产的
Shure: This is actually a specialty from the Northeast.
Jake:但差不多也长这样
Jake: But it looks similar.
Jake:我也吃不出来我也吃不出来
Jake: I can't tell the difference, I can't tell the difference.
Jake:这样我就觉得
Jake: So, I think...
Katrina: 还要那个青提
Katrina: Do we still need green grapes?
Shure: 青提每天买都每天吃是吧
Shure: Green grapes, we buy and eat them every day, right?
Katrina: 真好吃可以倒那个养乐多倒的
Katrina: They are really delicious, you can pour Yakult over them.
Katrina: 青提在哪呀
Katrina: Where are the green grapes?
Katrina: 你好有阳光玫瑰吗
Katrina: Hi, do you have Shine Muscat grapes?
Katrina: 就青提那种
Katrina: The green grape kind.
Katrina: 哦哦哦谢谢
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, thank you.
Katrina: 养乐多和旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Yakult and Wangzai Milk.
Katrina: 他这是打特价吗
Katrina: Is this on special offer?
Katrina: 为什么这么大一盒才15块钱
Katrina: Why is such a big box only 15 yuan?
Shure: 你们那看着
Shure: You guys look...
Shure: 你看跟这色都不一样
Shure: Look, the color is different here.
Katrina: 不太新鲜
Katrina: It's not very fresh.
Katrina: 哇这都能认错
Katrina: Wow, you can even mistake this.
Shure: 我不知道笋
Shure: I don't know bamboo shoots...
Katrina: 比我更无知的人出现了
Katrina: Someone more ignorant than me appeared.
Shure: 我想吃咸鸭蛋
Shure: I want to eat salted duck eggs.
Katrina: 有没有那种一个一个拿呗
Katrina: Are there ones you can take one by one?
Shure: 嗯我想吃咸鸭蛋
Shure: Hmm, I want to eat salted duck eggs.
Katrina: 咸鸭蛋是不是有单个卖的
Katrina: Don't they sell single salted duck eggs?
Katrina: 拿两个呗
Katrina: Take two then.
Katrina: 一两块钱不在话下
Katrina: One or two yuan, not a big deal.
Katrina: 好吧
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 这个是不是
Katrina: Is this...?
Katrina: 美文纸旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Meiyuan Paper Wangzai Milk.
Katrina: 还要买一瓶龙舌兰
Katrina: Also need to buy a bottle of tequila.
Katrina: 怎么吃上了就
Katrina: How come you started eating...?
Katrina: 嗯我也喜欢玩
Katrina: Hmm, I also like to play.
Katrina: 你要买什么
Katrina: What do you want to buy?
Tasha: 我没有要买
Tasha: I don't want to buy anything.
Tasha: 我只是觉得这个虾怎么这么大
Tasha: I just think this shrimp is so big.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 吃这个
Katrina: Let's eat this.
Katrina: 这么大
Katrina: It's so big.
Katrina: 好便宜啊
Katrina: And so cheap.
Katrina: 哈哈哈杨老板直接拿一袋啊
Katrina: Haha, Jake, just grab a bag.
Choiszt: 哈哈看着不是很新鲜
Choiszt: Haha, it doesn't look very fresh.
Katrina: 嗯哎今天晚上吃什么
Katrina: Hmm, what are we eating tonight?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Nicous: 这哪有有垃圾桶你扔了
Nicous: There's a trash can, throw it there.
Choiszt: 扔地上
Choiszt: Throw it on the ground.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Choiszt: 素质最大化
Choiszt: Maximum rudeness.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 哈你看这就是老北京的地道咱说
Shure: Haha, you see, this is the authentic old Beijing style.
Katrina: 松弛感哈哈
Katrina: The relaxed vibe, haha.
Shure: 今天晚上
Shure: Tonight...
Shure: 麦当劳吧麦当劳
Shure: McDonald's, let's do McDonald's.
Katrina: 我靠吃上周黑鸭了
Katrina: Wow, we're having Zhou Hei Ya.
Shure: 啊对你把牛排煎了吧
Shure: Oh right, you fry the steak.
Choiszt: 这个糕点呢
Choiszt: And this pastry?
Katrina: 是不是周黑鸭
Katrina: Is this Zhou Hei Ya?
Choiszt: 糕点有人吃吗
Choiszt: Anyone eating the pastry?
Shure: 这就下酒啊
Shure: It's great with drinks.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my.
Jake:拿这么多您还需要什么
Jake: You got so much, need anything else?
Katrina: 哇好
Katrina: Wow, okay.
Jack: 好我们俩晚饭已经吃过了今天你们自己安排
Jack: Okay, we already had dinner, you guys figure it out.
Katrina: 吃方便面
Katrina: Instant noodles.
Katrina: 这拿来当早饭还是当明天的糕点
Katrina: Is this for breakfast or tomorrow's pastry?
Katrina: 晚上的糕点
Katrina: Evening pastry.
Jake:晚上我们要做糕点
Jake: We are making pastries tonight.
Jake:晚上我们要做很多很多
Jake: We're making a lot tonight.
Jake:很多很多
Jake: A lot.
Katrina: 昨天做了麻薯
Katrina: We made mochi yesterday.
Shure: 那麻薯
Shure: That mochi.
Shure: 盒马的这种瑞士卷特别好吃
Shure: The Swiss rolls from Hema are really good.
Katrina: 没吃过
Katrina: Never tried them.
Katrina: 去拿养乐多吧
Katrina: Go get some Yakult.
Katrina: 养乐多应该在哪
Katrina: Where's the Yakult?
Shure: 哈哈惦记半天了快去吧
Shure: Haha, you've been thinking about it for a while, go get it.
Katrina: 必须
Katrina: Definitely.
Katrina: 小时候最喜欢吃黄桃果粒了
Katrina: When I was a kid, I loved eating peach fruit chunks.
Shure: 我也是还有那个桑椹的
Shure: Me too, and the mulberry ones.
Katrina: 黄桃这个
Katrina: This peach one.
Katrina: 嗯哎
Katrina: Hmm, yeah.
Shure: 我特别喜欢吃
Shure: I really like eating it.
Katrina: 这是优益c
Katrina: This is Your-C.
Katrina: 这不是养乐多
Katrina: This isn't Yakult.
Katrina: 嗯他那个吃了嘴巴里酸酸的
Katrina: Hmm, when you eat it, it makes your mouth feel sour.
Katrina: 拿两排吧
Katrina: Let's get two packs.
Katrina: 这边好像没有看到酒哎
Katrina: Seems like there's no alcohol here.
Katrina: 在一楼吗
Katrina: Is it on the first floor?
Shure: 咱俩进门的时候看到的
Shure: We saw it when we entered the door.
Katrina: 汪汪队
Katrina: Paw Patrol.
Katrina: 汪汪队我们马上就到无论大小麻烦
Katrina: Paw Patrol, we'll be there soon, no matter big or small trouble.
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶在哪里啊
Katrina: Where's the Wangzai milk?
Jack: 我们现在只剩一辆
Jack: We only have one car left now.
Katrina: 你们车呢
Katrina: Where's your car?
Jake:车丢了
Jake: The car is lost.
Jack: 唉正好丢了
Jack: Well, it just got lost.
Jack: 有东西那个车健康的Pad还在里面
Jack: There's stuff in the car, a healthy Pad is still inside.
Jack: 哈哈哈丢了个Pad
Jack: Hahaha, we lost a Pad.
Shure: 哈哈哈乐死了
Shure: Hahaha, that's hilarious.
Shure: 车都车都不经过好了
Shure: The car, the car, it's all gone.
Lucia: 有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina: 哦买噶太皮了有点
Katrina: Oh my god, you're a bit too naughty.
Katrina: 去找旺仔牛奶吧
Katrina: Let's go find the Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 我们以前小学喝这个
Katrina: We used to drink this in elementary school.
Katrina: 就学校给发这个
Katrina: The school gave it out.
Shure: 高钙奶
Shure: High calcium milk.
Katrina: 一袋一袋的
Katrina: In little bags.
Katrina: 杨梅汁
Katrina: Bayberry juice.
Katrina: 没看见旺仔牛奶呀
Katrina: I didn't see any Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 问一下
Katrina: Let's ask.
Katrina: 您好请问旺仔牛奶在哪里
Katrina: Excuse me, where's the Wangzai milk?
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶啊
Katrina: Wangzai milk?
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: 一楼饮料的
Katrina: The drinks on the first floor.
Nicous: 这个想吃了
Nicous: I want to eat this.
Katrina: 吃
Katrina: Eat it.
Nicous: 那还能不吃
Nicous: How can I not eat it?
Katrina: 非要我点头是吧
Katrina: You really need me to nod, huh?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 我倒时候带回武汉去了
Katrina: I'll take it back to Wuhan later.
Katrina: 嗯吃哈哈哈
Katrina: Mm, eat it, hahaha.
Katrina: 这个不吃这奶味
Katrina: Not eating this, it tastes like milk.
Katrina: 不是高铁上推销呢
Katrina: Isn't this like the stuff they sell on high-speed trains?
Katrina: 嗯我想吃青柠味的
Katrina: I want to eat the lime-flavored one.
Nicous: 这个青柠和黄瓜都可以
Nicous: Both the lime and cucumber ones are good.
Nicous: 嗯那就这个吧
Nicous: Mm, let's go with this one then.
Katrina: 哎呀哈哈哈还大的好吃
Katrina: Oh my, hahaha, the bigger one tastes better.
Shure: 一新币哎
Shure: One Singapore dollar.
Nicous: 咖啡还要吗
Nicous: Do you still want coffee?
Katrina: 咖啡不用了吧
Katrina: No more coffee, right?
Nicous: 不是我现在感觉那个写的
Nicous: I feel like that shopping list is pointless now.
Nicous: 那个购物清单没有意义啊
Nicous: That shopping list has no meaning anymore.
Nicous: 我来一个
Nicous: I'll have one.
Nicous: 祝我永远的给你们激发灵感
Nicous: May I always inspire you guys.
Katrina: 公费吃喝
Katrina: Eating and drinking on the company’s dime.
Katrina: 那我想想我还有什么想吃的
Katrina: Let me think if there's anything else I want to eat.
Shure: 找着了吗
Shure: Did you find it?
Lucia: 嗯找着了
Lucia: Mm-hmm, found it.
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What's this?
Lucia: 西梅
Lucia: Prunes.
Shure: 是吃的吗
Shure: Is it edible?
Lucia: 是啊啊不是
Lucia: Yes, no, not really.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Katrina: 哈他们拿那么多饮料干啥
Katrina: Ha, why are they grabbing so many drinks?
Katrina: 我们这是把那个to do list都完成了
Katrina: We completed that to-do list.
Shure: 我们这都完成了
Shure: We completed it.
Jake:你们to do完了
Jake: You guys completed the to-do list?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Nicous: 自由发挥了
Nicous: Now we can do whatever we want.
Jake:哈哈哈啊我看看有多少自由发挥了
Jake: Hahaha, let me see how much "whatever we want" you’ve done.
Choiszt: 你的两头不太够吃
Choiszt: You don't have enough on both ends.
Jake:哈哈哈这个人也挺自由啊
Jake: Hahaha, this guy is pretty free-spirited.
Jake:哈哈哈还有吗
Jake: Hahaha, is there more?
Katrina: 买了下面都是食用的
Katrina: The rest are all edible.
Jake:那这些是干嘛的
Jake: Then what are these for?
Katrina: 这是小食
Katrina: These are snacks.
Shure: 这些这也是给嘉宾
Shure: These are also for the guests.
Shure: 就是
Shure: That's right.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 因为中中国有句古话叫有朋自远方来
Shure: Because there's an old Chinese saying, "When a friend comes from afar..."
Shure: 不亦乐乎
Shure: "...isn't it a joy?"
其他人：虽远必诛
Others: "...punish them even if they are far away."
Katrina: 哈哈哈你有几个朋友
Katrina: Hahaha, how many friends do you have?
Katrina: 你就
Katrina: You just...
Nicous: 你没看过那个阿巴斯的评论
Nicous: Haven't you seen Abbas's comments?
Katrina: 没有看过
Katrina: No, I haven't.
Lucia: 这是一那种新新的弱智吧吗
Lucia: Is this a new kind of idiot?
Nicous: 我操我给你看一下
Nicous: Damn, let me show you.
Nicous: 你竟然没看过阿巴斯
Nicous: You haven't seen Abbas?
Katrina: 下一楼
Katrina: Next floor.
Shure: 你们还有啥没买
Shure: Did you buy everything you need?
Katrina: 旺仔牛奶跟
Katrina: Want Want Milk and...
Katrina: 旺旺仔牛奶跟龙舌兰
Katrina: Want Want Milk and tequila.
Lucia: 神经病哈哈哈
Lucia: Crazy, hahaha.
Lucia: 如果你来我家的话我会请你吃冰淇淋
Lucia: If you come to my place, I'll treat you to ice cream.
Katrina: 哦哦哦我看过这个
Katrina: Oh, I've seen this.
Katrina: 就是一个外国人
Katrina: It's a foreigner.
Katrina: 然后大家都在他评论区里说一些中文
Katrina: And everyone leaves him comments in broken Chinese.
Katrina: 语法颠倒的那种乱七八糟的
Katrina: Messed up grammar and all that.
Jake:他在学中文是吧
Jake: He's learning Chinese, right?
Katrina: 去一楼不
Katrina: Going to the first floor?
Katrina: 哦一楼
Katrina: Oh, first floor.
Katrina: 从那下
Katrina: Go down from there.
Katrina: 我看到有一个人头慢慢的下去
Katrina: I saw someone's head slowly going down.
Katrina: 这边下去是不是
Katrina: Go down here, right?
Nicous: 阿巴斯你记住是金子总会发光
Nicous: Abbas, remember, gold will shine.
Nicous: 但是你是老铁
Nicous: But you're solid.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Shure: 老铁
Shure: Solid.
Katrina: 但是你是
Katrina: But you are...
Nicous: 阿巴斯景色不断
Katrina: 50钱那景色有多少钱哈哈
Shure: 还是25 人
Nicous: 阿巴斯你记住
Nicous: 你在食堂吃饭报我的名字
Nicous: 你可以享受原价
Nicous: 阿巴我操
Nicous: 这个是最逆天的
Nicous: 阿巴斯你记住
Nicous: 太空有太空
Nicous: 太空有空间站
Nicous: 太挤就没有空间站
Katrina: 哦
Shure: 啊啊我靠牛逼
Katrina: 明白了
Katrina: 再下去吧
Katrina: 我就说看到有人头缓缓的下去
Katrina: 咱里面可还是有杯子
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: 哈哈我同学crush crush
Shure: 那个红衣服是你同学crush
Shure: That person in the red is your classmate's crush?
Shure: 是吗啊
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 他跟人家用情头呢
Katrina: They even use matching profile pictures.
Nicous: 这个吗
Nicous: This one?
Katrina: 开他玩笑
Katrina: Just teasing him.
Katrina: 他
Katrina: He...
Katrina: 嗯他俩认识很久了
Katrina: Yeah, they've known each other for a long time.
Katrina: 然后他妈就跟他说
Katrina: Then his mom told him,
Katrina: 你你俩要不在一起得了
Katrina: Why don't you two just get together?
Katrina: 就是这个女生从来不找男朋友嘛
Katrina: Because this girl never looks for a boyfriend.
Katrina: 谁又喜欢
Katrina: Who else likes her?
Katrina: 这倒长得挺帅哈
Katrina: But he's quite handsome.
Katrina: 这把华科去了
Katrina: Then he went to Huake.
Katrina: 我靠他从南航到华科
Katrina: Wow, he went from Nanhang to Huake.
Katrina: 我从武理里到东南
Katrina: I went from Wuli to Dongnan.
Katrina: 咱俩交换地狱呢
Katrina: We're swapping places in hell.
Nicous: 这就是缘分
Nicous: That's just fate.
Shure: （歌词）缘分让我们相遇乱世以外
Shure: (Lyrics) Fate brought us together beyond this chaotic world.
Katrina: 你知道当时我同
Katrina: You know, back then my classmate...
Katrina: 我是我同学
Katrina: I was my classmate...
Katrina: 就是说要介绍我俩认识
Katrina: So, they want to introduce us.
Katrina: 那男的看
Katrina: That guy looked
Katrina: 我朋友圈说我太潮了
Katrina: at my social media and said I'm too trendy.
Katrina: 高攀不起
Katrina: He can't keep up with me.
Shure: 风湿病犯了是吗
Shure: Did his rheumatism act up?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 我哪潮了
Katrina: How am I trendy?
Katrina: 我想请问
Katrina: I'd like to ask.
Katrina: 他线下见我以后
Katrina: After he meets me in person,
Katrina: 就觉得不会觉得我是潮人了
Katrina: he won't think I'm trendy.
Shure: 粉毛染的吧
Shure: It's probably the pink hair.
Katrina: 可能吧粉毛吓着人家了
Katrina: Maybe, the pink hair scared him.
Katrina: 乖乖男一枚
Katrina: He's such a goody-two-shoes.
Katrina: 乖乖男一枚啊
Shure: 妈妈不让我带
Shure: My mom won't let me
Shure: 找染头发并且有纹身的女生
Shure: date girls with dyed hair and tattoos.
Katrina: 咦
Katrina: Eh.
Katrina: 确定这会有龙舌兰吗
Katrina: Are you sure they have tequila here?
Shure: 有吧
Shure: I think so.
Katrina: 旺仔和龙舌兰
Katrina: Milk tea and tequila.
Katrina: 这会有龙舌兰吗
Katrina: Do they have tequila here?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 他这没有龙舌兰
Shure: They don't have tequila here.
Shure: 他咋没了
Shure: Why don't they have it?
Shure: 身上全是这种气泡酒的
Shure: They only have these sparkling wines.
Katrina: 白兰地是什么酒
Katrina: What kind of wine is brandy?
Katrina: 难道
Katrina: Could it be...
Shure: 没了
Shure: It's gone.
Shure: 完了那一会外卖吧
Shure: Alright, we'll order takeout later.
Katrina: 旺仔还没拿呢
Katrina: The milk tea hasn't been picked up yet.
Katrina: 他说在一楼
Katrina: He said it's on the first floor.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 您好请问旺仔牛奶在哪
Katrina: Excuse me, where's the milk tea?
Katrina: 在哪
Katrina: Where is it?
Katrina: 哦哦这是吗
Katrina: Oh, is this it?
Katrina: 啊这太多了
Katrina: Ah, that's too much.
Katrina: 问一下他要多少来着
Katrina: Let me ask him how much he wanted.
Katrina: 微微对薇薇
Katrina: Tasha for Tasha.
Katrina: 2罐够吗够了
Katrina: Are two cans enough? Yeah, that's enough.
Shure: 没有啊
Shure: There's none.
Katrina: 没有那就点外卖吧
Katrina: If we don't have it, let's order delivery.
Shure: 点外卖呗
Shure: Order delivery then.
Shure: 然后还可以二锅头兑那什么
Shure: And we can mix Erguotou with...
Shure: 兑那个西柚汁
Shure: ...with grapefruit juice.
Katrina: 我只喝旺仔牛奶
Katrina: I only drink Wangzai milk.
Katrina: 这个称了吗
Katrina: Is this weighed?
Katrina: 西梅
Katrina: Prunes.
Nicous: 一楼称
Nicous: Weigh it on the first floor.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Jack: 这个一楼称吗
Jack: Is this weighed on the first floor?
Lucia: 他说结账的那个称
Lucia: He said the one for checkout.
Katrina: 嗯他他是做甜点用
Katrina: Hmm, he's using it for making desserts.
Katrina: 应该调味的
Katrina: Should be for seasoning.
Jack: 两瓶两个车形成鲜明的对比
Jack: Two bottles, two cars, what a contrast.
Nicous: 我觉得这个这么多东西三个人吃
Nicous: I think all this food is for three people.
Nicous: 三个人就吃完了
Nicous: Three people can finish it.
Jack: 那建议你速速找
Jack: Then I suggest you quickly find...
Jack: 健康要方便
Jack: ...something healthy and convenient.
Nicous: 这是买给嘉宾吃的吗
Nicous: Is this for the guests?
Nicous: 不可能啊
Nicous: No way.
Nicous: 这个东西很很危害健康啊
Nicous: This stuff is really unhealthy.
Nicous: 吃吃瓜子会上火
Nicous: Eating sunflower seeds can cause heatiness.
Katrina: 话筒怎么解决来着话筒
Katrina: How do we handle the microphones?
Shure: 话筒明天他们从北邮带
Shure: They'll bring the microphones from Beiyou tomorrow.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Katrina: 都不能吃
Katrina: None of it is edible.
Katrina: 都不健康
Katrina: None of it is healthy.
Katrina: 全部给你带回去
Katrina: Take it all back.
Katrina: 懂得分享
Katrina: Learn to share.
Katrina: 那就差一个酒吧
Katrina: We just need one more bar.
Choiszt: 这个咸鸭蛋
Choiszt: This salted duck egg...
Katrina: 这咸鸭蛋是
Katrina: This salted duck egg is...
Katrina: 修硕自己想家了想吃
Katrina: Shure misses home and wants to eat it.
Choiszt: 修硕你那个咸鸭蛋
Choiszt: Shure, when will you eat this salted duck egg?
Choiszt: 要什么情景下吃
Choiszt: Under what circumstances?
Shure: 今天晚上吃
Shure: Tonight.
Shure: 就着汉堡好吃
Shure: It's good with a burger.
Jack: 咸鸭蛋配汉堡
Jack: Salted duck egg with a burger?
Jack: 中西结合
Jack: East meets West.
Shure: 我得好这口
Shure: I have a taste for this.
Shure: 想太久了你
Shure: You took too long to think.
Shure: 今天中午吃的卤煮
Shure: Had some braised pork for lunch.
Shure: 但那卤煮不行
Shure: But it wasn't good.
Shure: 不地道
Shure: Not authentic.
Nicous: 你们都吃卤煮
Nicous: You all had braised pork?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: More or less.
Jack: 我好奇刘帅
Jack: I'm curious, Choiszt.
Jack: 你是北京人
Jack: You're from Beijing, right?
Jack: 你能喝豆汁吗
Jack: Can you drink fermented mung bean milk?
Choiszt: 不喝不是
Choiszt: No, I can't.
Choiszt: 我都没怎么吃过那个北京小吃
Choiszt: I haven't really tried much of the Beijing snacks.
Jack: 真的吗你从小到大都没吃过
Jack: Really? You haven't had them your whole life?
Choiszt: 那都是人家老北
Choiszt: Those are for the old Beijingers.
Choiszt: 那些老北京人
Choiszt: The real old Beijingers.
Shure: 你家哪区的
Shure: Which district are you from?
Choiszt: 就海淀区
Choiszt: Just Haidian District.
Choiszt: 哎这小瓶刚买了俩大瓶
Choiszt: Hey, this small bottle just bought two big ones.
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, that's the one.
Jake:稍微便宜
Jake: It's slightly cheaper.
Jake:能便宜个一毛半
Jake: You can save about one and a half cents.
Shure: 一毛半新币
Shure: One and a half cents in new currency?
Choiszt: 为了这一毛半
Choiszt: For that one and a half cents?
Choiszt: 然后在这纠结
Choiszt: And you hesitated over this?
Choiszt: 然后买了好多额外的
Choiszt: Then bought a bunch of extra stuff.
Tasha: 抠抠搜搜花了很多
Tasha: Being stingy, spent a lot.
Nicous: 不是
Nicous: No...
Nicous: 这个和这个放在一起我有点于心不忍
Nicous: Putting this and this together, I feel a bit uneasy.
Tasha: 为什么
Tasha: Why?
Nicous: 那搁那车里
Nicous: Leaving it in the car.
Shure: 都是meta付
Shure: It's all meta payments.
Shure: 不是吗
Shure: Isn't it?
Shure: 是不是咱们开发票
Shure: Aren't we invoicing?
Shure: 开什么脸书有限公司是吗
Shure: What do we invoice as? Facebook Ltd.?
Jack: 我们只能开
Jack: We can only invoice...
Jack: 感觉时间有限
Jack: Time seems limited.
Shure: 我们开发票的话应该开什么
Shure: What should we invoice under?
Katrina: 走吧
Katrina: Let's go.
Katrina: 前面结
Katrina: Settle it upfront.
Shure: 但是国外报销他走发票这一套吗
Shure: But do foreign reimbursements go through this invoice process?
Katrina: 这能结吗
Katrina: Can this be settled?
Jack: 这个还要称重
Jack: This still needs to be weighed.
Shure: 真的呀
Shure: Really?
Katrina: 当心当心
Katrina: Be careful, be careful.
Shure: 不是他
Shure: It's not him.
Shure: 他弄一个然后共享咱们贴就行
Shure: He can make one and then share it, and we can just post it.
Jake:你懂吗你懂吗你懂吗
Jake: Do you understand? Do you understand? Do you understand?
Nicous: 你可能还不太懂
Nicous: You might not quite get it yet.
Jake:哈哈哈可能下个月让你懂一懂
Jake: Haha, maybe next month you'll understand a bit more.
Lucia: 哈哈我们要不要来一份
Lucia: Haha, should we get a portion?
Lucia: 请嘉宾喝茶
Lucia: Invite the guest for tea.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much?
Lucia: 319
Lucia: 319.
Shure: 60新币而已
Shure: Just 60 Singapore dollars.
Lucia: 6但是他们家茶真的很好
Lucia: Yeah, but their tea is really good.
Lucia: 这应该是一个北京老字号
Lucia: This should be an old Beijing brand.
Jack: 回到中国
Jack: Back to China.
Jack: 什么东西一除五就感觉没有
Jack: Once you divide something by five, it feels like nothing.
Katrina: 不是为啥他会刷到我呀
Katrina: Why did he swipe to me?
Katrina: 我真服了
Katrina: I'm really speechless.
Katrina: 应该是你跟他有通讯录的关系吧
Katrina: It must be because you have some contact info with him.
Katrina: 我小红书跟人做那个自媒体呢
Katrina: I'm doing social media on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina: 你就是有点偏营销那种
Katrina: You're kind of into marketing.
Katrina: 因为想涨粉和接广告呀
Katrina: Because you want to gain followers and get ads.
Katrina: 就是不是跟抖音一样发着玩了
Katrina: It's not like playing around on TikTok.
Katrina: 我过两天就回来
Katrina: I'll be back in a couple of days.
Katrina: 我票都订好了
Katrina: I've already booked my ticket.
Katrina: 怎么想我了吗
Katrina: Did you miss me?
Shure: 啊好好好
Shure: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure: 袋子要要要
Shure: We need the bag, yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 多点哎
Katrina: A bit more, hey.
Katrina: 没有会员怎么办
Katrina: What if we don't have a membership?
Katrina: 哦好的
Katrina: Oh, okay.
Katrina: 查哪个码
Katrina: Which code to check?
Katrina: 有袋子吗拿来
Katrina: Do you have a bag? Give it to me.
Katrina: 嗯拿那个吧
Katrina: Yeah, take that one.
Katrina: 嗯对
Katrina: Yeah, right.
Choiszt: 这个杯子这个杯子你
Choiszt: This cup, this cup, you...
Jack: 好
Jack: Okay.
Jack: 你好你好
Jack: Hi, hi.
Katrina: 一起一起
Katrina: Together, together.
Katrina: 送了个洗衣凝珠啊
Katrina: They gave us a laundry detergent pod.
Katrina: 需要开发票吗
Katrina: Do you need an invoice?
Jake:不要开发票
Jake: No need for an invoice.
Katrina: 那不用不用
Katrina: No need then, no need.
Katrina: 为什么我们这边这么多才400多
Katrina: Why is it only over 400 here?
Katrina: 再拿一个不
Katrina: Should we get another one?
Katrina: 再拿一个塑料袋吧
Katrina: Let's grab another plastic bag.
Katrina: 搞一个护杯使者吧
Katrina: Let's get a cup protector.
Choiszt: 还没出超市
Choiszt: Haven't left the supermarket yet.
Choiszt: 是不是碎了啊
Choiszt: Is it broken?
Jake:已经碎了啊
Jake: It's already broken.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Choiszt: 碎了也不能换了
Choiszt: Even if it's broken, we can't exchange it.
Katrina: 拿着吧反正就几个袋子
Katrina: Just take it, it's just a few bags anyway.
Katrina: 这么多人
Katrina: So many people.
Katrina: 我们下去开车
Katrina: Let's go downstairs and drive.
Shure: 这两个东西你们是不是要拿拿拿出去
Shure: Do you need to take these two things out?
Shure: 不是这两个拿出去
Shure: No, these two need to be taken out.
Shure: OK车就不用拿了
Shure: Okay, the car doesn't need to be taken out.
Shure: 就放这吧
Shure: Just leave it here.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Shure: 再见
Shure: See you.
Katrina: 还有两个杯子在哪
Katrina: Where are the other two cups?
Nicous: 都在这里面
Nicous: They're all in here.
Nicous: 那里
Nicous: Over there.
Shure: 上车把这个关掉
Shure: Get in the car and turn this off.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 有味道吗
Katrina: Does it smell?
Choiszt: 哎他们那个烤箱
Choiszt: Hey, their oven...
Nicous: 还有一个杯子呢
Nicous: There's another cup.
Choiszt: 不管
Choiszt: Never mind.
Katrina: 轻点就行
Katrina: Just be gentle.
Shure: 因为菠萝菠萝蜜
Shure: Because of the pineapple, pineapple honey.
Shure: 菠萝菠萝蜜
Shure: Pineapple, pineapple honey.
Katrina: 带我去带我去
Katrina: Take me there, take me there.
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What's this?
Nicous: 这是之前美团
Nicous: This is from Meituan before.
Nicous: 美团改小象超市改名
Nicous: Meituan changed its name to Xiaoxiang Supermarket.
Nicous: 改名成美团的时候送的东西
Nicous: It was a gift when they changed the name to Meituan.
Nicous: 哦这不是美团超市改成小象超市
Nicous: Oh, isn't this Meituan Supermarket changed to Elephant Supermarket?
Nicous: 送的吗
Nicous: Did they deliver it?
Choiszt: 哪个右边
Choiszt: Which one on the right?
Nicous: 就这个大的
Nicous: This big one.
Nicous: 大米的就这个篓
Nicous: The rice one, this basket.
Choiszt: 小心一点
Choiszt: Be careful.
Katrina: 你拿着吃吧
Katrina: You hold it and eat.
Katrina: 哎我想吃那个
Katrina: Oh, I want to eat that.
Nicous: 你想吃巧克力是吧
Nicous: You want to eat chocolate, right?
Katrina: 我想吃我想吃
Katrina: I want to eat, I want to eat.
Choiszt: 你先把眼镜关掉
Choiszt: Turn off your glasses first.
Choiszt: 然后想拿什么
Choiszt: Then decide what you want to take.
Shure: 你刚刚没关
Shure: You didn't turn it off just now.
Shure: 你放回去
Shure: Put it back.
Shure: 你拿这个干什么呀
Shure: What are you taking this for?
Shure: 谢冰竹不
Shure: Thank you Bingzhu, no?
Katrina: 哎不好意思
Katrina: Oh, sorry.
Shure: 好意思这杯子放这吗
Shure: Is it okay to put this cup here?
Katrina: 拿着吧
Katrina: Hold it.
Katrina: 拿吧我俩不看你
Katrina: Hold it, we won't watch you.
Katrina: 我不吃不吃你吃吧
Katrina: I won't eat, won't eat, you eat.
Shure: 谢冰竹你干什么呢
Shure: Thank you Bingzhu, what are you doing?
Katrina: 哈哈哈你说这个很容易碎
Katrina: Haha, you said this is very fragile.
Katrina: 要拿着巧克力也得拿在身上
Katrina: If you take the chocolate, you have to keep it on you.
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato.
Katrina: 我给你开门
Katrina: I'll open the door for you.
Katrina: 你是大老爷
Katrina: You're the big boss.
Shure: 是的你不得还得扶着吗
Shure: Yes, don't you need to hold it?
Katrina: 哎哎呀你别磕着哈哈
Katrina: Oh, oh, don't bump into anything, haha.
Shure: 怎么没学全套呢
Shure: Why didn't you learn the whole set?
Katrina: 所以被开了呀
Katrina: So I got fired, right?
Shure: 哎呦这谁不开你啊
Shure: Oh come on, who wouldn't fire you?
Shure: 就你这样
Shure: Acting like this.
Katrina: 带我去带我去
Katrina: Take me, take me.
Katrina: 放中间吧
Katrina: Put it in the middle.
Katrina: 我要吃一个
Katrina: I want to eat one.
Shure: 我不吃我不吃
Shure: I won't eat, I won't eat.
Katrina: 这华艺术
Katrina: This is artistic.
Katrina: 你干啥了呀
Katrina: What did you do?
Katrina: 你就累了
Katrina: Are you just tired?
Katrina: 你最近在
Katrina: What have you been
Katrina: 干什么呢
Katrina: up to lately?
Choiszt: 没没有吧
Choiszt: No, I haven't.
Choiszt: 应该在后备箱吧
Choiszt: It should be in the trunk.
Nicous: 没有没有没有
Nicous: No, no, no.
Nicous: 我拿着的
Nicous: I'm holding it.
Choiszt: 我关了窗户找找
Choiszt: I'll close the window and check.
Choiszt: 哎这个窗户我没关吗
Choiszt: Hey, did I not close this window?
Katrina: 不是他来找你打听我还是咋的
Katrina: Did he come to ask you about me or something?
Shure: 谁呀怎么了
Shure: Who? What's up?
Katrina: 就是有一个人叫女生
Katrina: There was someone, a girl
Shure: 女生打听你
Shure: A girl asked about you?
Katrina: 嗯我初中也被女生喜欢过
Katrina: Yeah, a girl liked me in middle school too.
Katrina: 就是我我当时不太懂这些
Katrina: Back then, I didn't really get it.
Katrina: 后来才知道他伤我
Katrina: Later, I found out she got hurt.
Katrina: 伤了他的心
Katrina: I hurt her feelings.
Katrina: 关哦你
Katrina: Oh, you closed it
Katrina: 关了已经
Katrina: It's already closed.
Nicous: 转球CCTR又被踢了
Nicous: Got kicked out of CCTR again.
Nicous: 今天转ECCV了
Nicous: Switching to ECCV today.
Nicous: 5月7号出的
Nicous: Came out on May 7th.
Katrina: 你那个做的是跟什么有关的好像
Katrina: What was your project about again?
Nicous: 我操其实我做的那特别好玩
Nicous: Damn, my project was actually really fun.
Nicous: 就是我们当时知不知道超级变变变
Nicous: Do you remember the "Super Transformation"?
Katrina: 超级什么
Katrina: Super what?
Nicous: 超级变变变这个东西啊
Nicous: "Super Transformation", you know.
Katrina: 我不知道
Katrina: I don't know it.
Katrina: 没看过
Katrina: Never watched it.
Nicous: 就是我们那个视频可以采集了
Nicous: So, we can gather videos.
Nicous: 三种类型
Nicous: Three types.
Nicous: 一种是沙雕短视频
Nicous: One is funny short clips.
Nicous: 一种是魔术视频
Nicous: Another is magic videos.
小黄: 一种是这种奇装异服的视频
Nicous: The third is videos with crazy costumes.
Nicous: 然后我们找人标注
Nicous: Then we get people to label them.
Nicous: 让人去回答这个视频哪里有趣了
Nicous: Have people explain what's funny about the video.
Nicous: 嗯然后做这种QA回答数据集
Nicous: Then we make a QA dataset.
Nicous: 嗯然后让大模型去回答测
Nicous: And have a big model answer it.
Katrina: 然后呢
Katrina: And then?
Nicous: 然后
Nicous: Then...
Katrina: 大模型就是整个这个模型的
Katrina: The big model is like the whole framework of this, right?
Katrina: 大模型用的是自己组里设计的这种
Katrina: Is the big model designed by your team?
Nicous: 对有我们自己做的模型
Nicous: Yeah, we built it ourselves.
Jack: 他这边有
Jack: He's got it here.
Jake:这个修叫什么
Jake: What's this repair thing?
Jake:回收旧的电琴
Jake: Recycling old electric pianos.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Katrina: 把钢琴拿过来卖
Katrina: Bringing in pianos to sell.
Nicous: 没问题
Nicous: No problem.
Nicous: 就是现在不有很多v型来规模的
Nicous: There are so many V-shaped models now.
Nicous: 我们都知道
Nicous: We all know.
Nicous: 发现他们回答都一坨屎
Nicous: But their answers are all crap.
Nicous: 然后我们自己也有模型
Nicous: And our model is also crap.
Nicous: 也是一坨
Nicous: Just like them.
Nicous: 就我们就也是做那种
Nicous: So we're also working on...
Nicous: 做奔驰马克
Nicous: Working on BenzMark.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Nicous: 希望大家多多往这方面做一做
Nicous: Hope everyone can work more on this.
Nicous: 要不然太low了
Nicous: Otherwise, it's too low-level.
Nicous: 现在模型
Nicous: Now the model
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 那总的主体
Katrina: So the overall main part
Katrina: 那核心模型就是他们组里的那种是吧
Katrina: The core model is from their group, right?
Katrina: 然后你们换换数据集啊
Katrina: And then you guys switch the dataset, yeah?
Katrina: 然后换换
Katrina: Then switch
Nicous: 这个工作就是重点不在模型性能上
Nicous: The focus of this work isn't on the model's performance
Nicous: 就是在数据集中线上啊
Nicous: It's mainly on the dataset online
Nicous: 这个是第一个这种有这种类型的数据
Nicous: This is the first dataset of this type
Nicous: 然后那会标的也很也很复杂
Nicous: And the labeling is very complex
Katrina: 感觉标数据是很大很大一坨
Katrina: It feels like labeling the data is a huge task
Katrina: 工作
Katrina: Job
Nicous: 除采集然后采集
Nicous: Besides collecting, you also need to collect
Nicous: 找人标就花很多时间才
Nicous: Finding people to label it takes a lot of time
Jack: 对但是
Jack: Yeah but
Jack: 但是几个几个人以上的群
Jack: But for groups with more than a few people
Katrina: 那你大二开始的吗
Katrina: Did you start this in your sophomore year?
Nicous: 大三
Nicous: Junior year
Katrina: 那爽啊大三到现在
Katrina: That's great, from junior year to now
Katrina: 一年多两篇论文爽的要死
Katrina: More than a year, two papers, that's awesome
Jack: 他自己比如说你公众号排满
Jack: For example, if you fill up your WeChat public account
Nicous: 还是不好升
Nicous: Still hard to get promoted
Katrina: CVPR都有了
Katrina: Even with CVPR
Katrina: 都不好升
Katrina: Still hard to get promoted
Katrina: 你几座给的
Katrina: What are your scores?
Katrina: 你要升哪个
Katrina: Which one do you want to apply to?
Katrina: 升南洋理工
Katrina: Applying to Nanyang Technological University
Nicous: 南洋理工已经没戏了
Nicous: Nanyang Technological University is not an option anymore
Nicous: 他现在不怎么招中国人
Nicous: They don't recruit many Chinese now
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Hmm, hmm
Katrina: 那你现在打算升哪一个呢
Katrina: So which one do you plan to apply to now?
Jack: 但是如果你做公众号那种因为你
Jack: But if you do a public account because you
Katrina: 港大你应该好升吧
Katrina: Hong Kong University should be easier for you
Katrina: 真的吗我我同学他们就也就是那种
Katrina: Really? My classmates also are like
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: No
Nicous: 说课说随便申
Nicous: They say it's easy to apply
Katrina: 哦你要升博
Katrina: Oh, you're applying for a PhD
Nicous: 研究升博
Nicous: Research for PhD
Katrina: 这个漏应该
Katrina: This leak should
Nicous: 但是就是这个差距太大了
Nicous: But the gap is just too big
Katrina: 升PhD可能
Katrina: Getting a PhD might
Nicous: 研究生特别好升
Nicous: It's really easy to get into grad school
Nicous: 是我们专业可能
Nicous: For our major maybe
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina: 我想的是他们那个
Katrina: I was thinking about their
Nicous: 七十多分就能去
Nicous: You can get in with just over seventy points
Jack: 就是就是
Jack: Exactly, exactly
Nicous: 因为我们有那个纪念品
Nicous: Because we have that souvenir
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 因为北邮的档次他就不在211这边
Katrina: Because Beiyou's rank isn't in the 211
Katrina: 在我们保邮的时候
Katrina: When we were at Beiyou
Katrina: 北邮就算终究在计算机
Katrina: Beiyou was still considered good in computer science
Nicous: 主要也就港大这个学校认北邮
Nicous: Mainly, only HKU recognizes Beiyou
Nicous: 别的学校可能不知道
Nicous: Other schools might not know it
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Uh-huh
Katrina: 但是你们去除了港大
Katrina: But if you go outside of HKU
Katrina: 那其他几个都不够你们这档次啊
Katrina: The other schools just don't match your level
Katrina: 港科啊啥的
Katrina: Like HKUST or something
Nicous: THAD来说香港没有区别的
Nicous: For THAD, there's no difference in Hong Kong
Katrina: 主要主要看导师
Katrina: Mainly, it depends on the advisor
Katrina: 是不是哦
Katrina: Right?
Jack: 这是你把这是你
Jack: This is, this is you
Katrina: 那都是我双飞同学升的
Katrina: Those were my dual major classmates who got in
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Katrina: 那你还嗯美国升不了
Katrina: But you can't get into the US?
Katrina: 英国呢
Katrina: How about the UK?
Katrina: 英国是不是也不给
Katrina: The UK doesn't give
Nicous: 大部分CSC钱
Nicous: Most CSC money
Nicous: 太少了
Nicous: Too little
Nicous: 还得自己贴钱
Nicous: You have to pay extra yourself
Jake:大家先休息一下
Jake: Everyone take a break first
Jake:不要工作
Jake: Don't work
Tasha: 那这个眼镜就关掉了
Tasha: Then I'll turn off these glasses
Katrina: 啊呀妈
Katrina: Oh my god
Katrina: 打火机借我一下
Katrina: Lend me the lighter
Katrina: 我昨天那个没弄呢那手工
Katrina: I didn't finish that craft yesterday
Katrina: 难怪我我那天问他
Katrina: No wonder, I asked him that day
Katrina: 我说你们这个发论文这怎么弄
Katrina: I was asking how you guys handle publishing papers.
Katrina: 他说
Katrina: He said,
Katrina: 反正什么这个数据集是我们自己的
Katrina: anyway, this dataset is our own.
Katrina: 那个准确率就
Katrina: The accuracy...
Katrina: 无所谓他说就是模型已经在跑
Katrina: doesn't matter. He said the model is already running.
Katrina: 就是用的是其他的数据集
Katrina: It's using other datasets.
Katrina: 等我们这个采集标注完以后
Katrina: Once we finish collecting and labeling,
Katrina: 就很快就能发论文
Katrina: we can quickly publish the paper.
Katrina: 然后我当时就想
Katrina: At that moment, I thought,
Katrina: 我以为数据集是第一步你知道吗
Katrina: I thought the dataset was the first step, you know?
Katrina: 我说你还得训练模型呢
Katrina: I said you still need to train the model.
Katrina: 他说只要套进去就行了
Katrina: He said just plug it in.
Katrina: 反正也没人做
Katrina: Anyway, no one else is doing it.
Katrina: 他们准确率多少也无所谓啊
Katrina: So it doesn't matter what their accuracy is.
Nicous: 反正这个东西就没人做嘛
Nicous: Anyway, no one is doing this stuff.
Nicous: 我们就随便一个模型就可以了啊
Nicous: We can just use any model, right?
Nicous: 我我发nibos的时候我都没有propos
Nicous: When I published on Nibos, I didn't have a proposal of my own stuff.
Nicous: 自己的东西
Nicous: My own stuff.
Katrina: 那你就用直接用别人的模型吗
Katrina: So you just used someone else's model?
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yep.
Jack: 他们说要把GPT4V刷爆
Jack: They said they want to push GPT4V to its limits.
Nicous: 肯定牛逼啊
Nicous: Definitely awesome.
Katrina: 我操教程呢
Katrina: Damn, where's the tutorial?
Jack: 但是但是
Jack: But, but...
Jack: 如果他们支持Dynamic partation的话
Jack: If they support Dynamic Partition,
Jack: 你可以直接把它们拼成一张
Jack: you can directly merge them into one.
Choiszt: 这可以吗
Choiszt: Can this work?
Jack: 你可以拼我
Jack: You can merge it.
Jack: 我给紫薇打标的时候
Jack: When I was labeling for Ziwei,
Jack: 就是拼的就是mod view
Jack: I merged it, it's the mod view.
Jack: view是拼成一张图
Jack: The view was merged into one picture.
Jack: 拉拉不是1.6会支持2*3
Jack: Isn't 1.6 going to support 2*3?
Choiszt: 就是4个page啊
Choiszt: That's 4 pages.
Jack: 不是6个
Jack: No, it's 6 pages.
Jack: 直接拼成2*32*3
Jack: Directly merge into 2*3, 2*3.
Choiszt: 他也没做过什么铺
Choiszt: He hasn't really done any layout.
Jack: 你不需要铺就他会
Jack: You don't need to layout, it will...
Jack: 就是你只需要按照
Jack: You just need to,
Jack: 比如说你拼成以24*24的grade为单位的话
Jack: for example, merge it into a 24*24 grade unit,
Jack: 你就拼成2*3的拉瓦
Jack: then merge it into 2*3.
Jack: 1.6是自动切的
Jack: The 1.6 automatically switches.
Jack: 他会自动detect一个最合适的分辨率
Jack: It will automatically detect the best resolution.
Jack: 然后把它切开
Jack: And then switch to it.
Choiszt: 嗯
Choiszt: Hmm.
Jack: 但但我感觉拉瓦他们就是有
Jack: But I feel like Lava has something...
Choiszt: 不是就是他切的时候
Choiszt: No, when it switches...
Choiszt: 比如说切四个派式然后
Choiszt: For example, if it switches to four parts and then...
Katrina: 关了
Katrina: Turn it off.